robert spencer
muslim member of congress ilhan omar
wants to get rid of the fourth of july
as i understand it and replace it with
july as
islamic heritage month or something like
that why in the world does anyone give
her an audience i mean a number of
muslims in congress are pushing for the
recognition of unlimited contributions
by islam to the american system of
government is the whole premise
even logical to you no but ilhan omar is
a very important force in american
politics today because of the
radicalization of the left and the
democratic party and the open embrace of
anti-americanism
the stylishness the fashionable nature
of hating our own country with this
athletes taking a knee for the anthem or
turning their back on the flag and so on
this is all uh the atmosphere in which
somebody like ilhan omar who is openly
contemptuous of american american values
and
recently likened the united states to
hamas and the taliban
this is the atmosphere in which somebody
like that flourishes and so it is the uh
embrace of socialism of marxism and of
anti-americanism by the left that has
made ilhan omar somebody that nobody on
the left wants to cross
because she's saying what
their constituency believes
and they know that if they confront her
they'll lose that constituency and be
out of power and so they'd rather play
ball and make the deal with the devil
you